TAKEN RELATIVE TO WHAT THEY
EXPECTED.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>>> FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ INSISTS A PLEA DEAL
INVOLVING A CLOSE ASSOCIATE HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH HIM.
TODAY, JOEL GREENBERG IS
EXPECTED TO PLEAD GUILTY TO
SEVERAL FEDERAL CHARGES
INCLUDING CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING.
GAETZ IS ALSO UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR POSSIBLE
VIOLATIONS OF FEDERAL SEX
TRAFFICKING LAWS.
HE HAS REPEATEDLY DENIED ANY LAW
BREAKING, BUT GREENBERG'S
COOPERATION COULD LEAD TO MORE
LEGAL TROUBLE FOR GAETZ AS
NIKOLE KILLION REPORTS.
>> Reporter: THIS MORNING, THE
MAN CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ HAS
CALLED HIS WING MAN, JOEL
GREENBERG, IS EXPECTED TO PLEAD
GUILTY TO SIX FEDERAL CHARGES
RANGING FROM CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING TO WIRE FRAUD.
ACCORDING TO HIS PLEA AGREEMENT,
GREENBERG ADMITS TO BEING
INVOLVED IN SUGAR DADDY
RELATIONSHIPS WHERE HE PAID
WOMEN FOR SEX, INCLUDING A MINOR
THAT HE INTRODUCED TO OTHER
AD
ADULT MEN WHAT ENGAGED IN SEX
ACTS.
MULTIPLE SOURCES SAY ONE OF
THOSE MEN IS GAETZ.
INVESTIGATORS LOOKING INTO
WHETHER HERE HAD A SEXUAL
RELATIONSHIP WHEN THE GIRL WAS
17.
HOW CONCERNED SHOULD CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ BE RIGHT NOW?
>> CONGRESSMAN GAETZ NEEDS TO BE
CONCERNED EVEN IF HE IS 100%
INNOCENT.
>> Reporter: CBS NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST RIKKI KLIEMAN.
>> THE DETAILS THAT HAVE LEAKED
OUT IN THIS INVESTIGATION ARE
REALLY ON THE ONE HAND
TITILLATING AND ON THE OTHER
HAND CERTAINLY SORDID AND
DISTURBING.
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF CRIMES
THAT SIMPLY THE RUMOR OF THAT
KIND OF ACTIVITY MAKES YOU LOOK
SKEPTICALLY AT SOMEONE EVEN IF
THEY'RE PRESUMED INNOCENT.
>> THE CAN I ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS --
>> Reporter: GAETZ DECLINED TO
SPEAK WITH US, BUT HIS
SPOKESPERSON SAID CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ DOESN'T SEEM TO BE NAMED
NOR REFERSED IN MR. GREENBERG'S
PLEA.
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ HAS NEVER HAD
SEX WITH A MINOR AND HAS NEVER
PAID FOR SEX.
THE FLORIDA LAWMAKER APPEARS
UNDAUNTED, SIDING WITH MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREEN AND ADDRESSING AN
OHIO POLITICAL SUMMIT THIS
WEEKEND.
AT THAT GOP SUMMIT, CONGRESSMAN
GAETZ REPORTEDLY TOLD THE CROWD
HE'S BEING FALSELY ACCUSED OF
EXCHANGING MONEY FOR NAUGHTY
FAVORS.
A REMINDER THAT GAETZ HAS NOT
BEEN INDICTED AND HAS REPEATEDLY
DENIED THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
HI